bon comme tout va bien avec chrysler on
va faire une interview aux alertes aux
roses le tabac fisto - non est-ce que
vous avez besoin d'aimer pour faire
l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour aimer
des mets pour faire l'amour j'ai jamais
fait l'amour sans aimer l intérieur j un
jour d'aujourd'hui
j'aimerais aller mais pas la moins vous
préférez une femme qui baisent bien mais
qu'un infidèle ou une femme qui baisent
mal mais qui est fidèle fidélité avant
tout même si elle baisse mal mais j'ai
pas vraiment le choix
je redis la fidélité la fidélité est
plus importante que le plaisir
personnellement oui je veux me sentir en
confiance avec une personne
ces joyeuses beaucoup donc ouais il
donne à sentir ce prix final pas vouloir
mais avec vous maintenant pas toujours
un pas toujours d'accord et je vous
préférez faire l'amour avec 1000 femmes
toujours de la même manière
ou toujours avec la même femme de mille
manières différentes
toujours avec la même de mille manières
différentes
trouver un est-ce que vous préféreriez
que fils leur couche avec un autre en
pensant à vous ou couche avec vous en
pensant à un autre
j'adore avoir des choses à ces sportifs
sont ils
est-ce que vous préféreriez que chrysler
couche avec un autre en pensant à vous
ou avec vous en pensant à un autre
endroit du choix ce week end à coucher
avec moi en pensant à l'autre ensuite
une vraie qu'elle pense à qui alors que
l'hymne non mais alors est-ce que vous
préférez une femme comprend sans la
comprendre ou qu'on comprend sans la
prendre
le laisse 20 minutes je crois que les
femmes on les comprend jamais
complètement
si chrysler vous propose un soir une
partie à trois vous préférez que le
troisième ça soit un homme ou une femme
jeune et c'est à mon sens une femme une
femme et elle
j'ose espérer que c'est une femme aussi
alors il a épousé une [ __ ] qui
baissent de viva la vida
on a vécu hier
est ce que vous l'avez déjà fait dans
l'eau oui a toujours écrit cela
est-ce que vous pensez que rien n'est
salle quand on aime dans l'eau partir du
moment où les deux sont d'accord
voilà vous êtes trois cartons et de la
santé dans les hôpitaux ils sont
puissants ils ont mal pour mes sponsors
de fixer les limites et à partir du
moment où l'on sait que quand on aime
tout est possible quoi tout à fait un as
dernière question c'est la france et la
terre fabrice santoro est ce que sucer
c'est tromper
oui paris